ich will sich als mein vize sie sind die
lösung für manche ich bin eines großen
konzerns ich war schon
verteidigungsminister und ich war
stabschef im weißen haus
vizepräsident ist hauptsächlich ein
symbolischer top der titel ist schon
einmal programm denn er hat eine
doppelte bedeutung weiß im sinne von
vice präsident der vize präsident der
usa war aber eben auch in der bedeutung
den sünder laster verfehlungen alles
dass ich habe einen hohen respekt vor
regen
aber keiner hat bisher die welt die
wahre macht eines us-präsidenten spüren
lassen
dick cheney war der vize präsident der
usa unter dem präsidenten george bush in
den jahren 2000 bis 2008 das war die ära
in die die terroranschläge vom 11
september 2001 fielen und auch der irak
krieger ist eine folge dieser anschläge
dick cheney war in all diesen jahren
eine figur von der nicht allzu viel an
die öffentlichkeit tragen im gegenteil
ist es so dass bis heute er ist einer
der heimlichen richten politik gilt
allerdings war immer klar dass er viel
stärkeren einfluss auf die politik der
usa in diesen jahren ausgeübt hat als es
dem amt des vize-präsidenten
üblicherweise zusteht
er gilt als einer der die fäden gezogen
hat jenny eignet sich deshalb sehr gut
als schurke schurken figur für all
diejenigen die glauben dass in diesen
jahren die politik der usa im
wesentlichen dingen in die falsche
richtung gegangen ist die hälfte das
sagst du dir gerne etwas taschen die
andere hälfte sagt der schauspieler der
ein spielt christian bale hat einmal
mehr einen außergewöhnlichen akt
hingelegt bell ist er berühmt dafür dass
er sich gerne für rollen gröberen
informationen unter zieht jetzt spiele
eben denn dann doch ziemlich im lauf der
jahre ziemlich an gewicht zunehmen
cheney das heißt welt hat auch 20 kilo
zugenommen
mit hilfe von maske aber eben auch mit
hilfe von tatsächlicher körperliche
veränderung und er spielt diesen dick
cheney auf eine interessante weise dann
doch so dass er nicht nur eine reine
schurken figur sondern bis zu einem
gewissen grad geht es eben auch darum
ihn als einen menschen zu erkennen
zwei mal richtig aus der gefängniszelle
heraus wie einen zuerst einmal könnte
man sagen ich weiß ein biografischer
film aber das was eine mcafee hat geht
dann doch eine deutlich andere richtung
denn wo er sich in allen wesentlichen
fragen oder in vielen wesentlichen
fragen an die fakten hält geht es hin
doch in erster linie darum die chemie zu
verunglimpfen
für meine begriffe ist nicht ganz
einsichtig warum eine marke sich dieser
aufgabe unterzieht in dieser einen
singulären figur so etwas wie das
grundübel der amerikanischen politik der
letzten zehn zwanzig jahre zu sehen
einen mann so heißt es im trailer der
den lauf der geschichte für immer
verändert hat damit überschätzt cheney
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen der
tatsächlich natürlich in vielerlei
hinsicht zu kritisieren ist aber der so
auch wir hier im film gezeigt wird ja
letztendlich doch nichts anderes ist als
eine charge der weltgeschichte und so
fällt ich finde ich der film im grunde
mit seiner methode selber so ein
bisschen in die ins wort und vermag im
grunde seine liberale kritische
botschaft gar nicht selber ganz ernst zu
nehmen weil es ihm vor allem darum geht
sich die ganze zeit lustig zu machen
andererseits
wird das amt des vize-präsidenten auch
definiert vom präsidenten und vielleicht
kommen wir da zu einer anderen
interpretation
[Musik]